[Music]
liam hemsworth and Madison Brown pack on
the PDA
the 29 year old Hunger Games star in the
22-year old dynasty actress were snapped
kissing and canoodling on Friday night
after an evening of partying at the
flower shop and the alley cat amateur
theatre in New York City Liam kept it
casual in a navy jacket paired with
black jeans and brown boots while
Madison looked effortlessly chic in a
black long-sleeve shirt trousers and
black heels the pair was first
photographed together on Thursday
holding hands as they rode the subway
and grabbed lunch as for Liam's ex Miley
Cyrus well it seems she's moving on to
the slide away singer just showed her
new love interest Cody Simpson some love
on Instagram calling the 22 year old her
Pugh thing in the comments section of
his post from his Tiffany and Co men's
launch photo shoot meanwhile Cody had
this to say at the launch party Friday
night they gave me this nice sort of
simple band right here and I'd maybe do
this and get you know you can get it
engraved or do something like that I'd
maybe do something like that for someone
personalize it a little bit could he be
talking about Miley on Sunday the pair
was photographed grabbing coffee a day
after meeting up with Miley's mom Tish
for breakfast in Los Angeles the
longtime friends turned lovers have been
hanging out a lot since Cyrus split from
Catelyn Carter late last month so it
seems both Miley and Liam are happily
moving on
[Music]